[Music]  well it's time to share some home cook  pasta with someone I don't get to see  enough these days my friend Andy Richter  hey Andy hey Conan it's great to be here  sitting exactly six feet across from you  so what are we sharing today well today  Andy we're sharing a classic spaghetti  and meatballs top with prego  pasta sauce oh that looks good but why  did you specifically mention the brand  in pasta sauce you mean  prego pasta sauce no reason now let's  dig in  oh wow that sauce is really thick I  can't wait to try it this is the  traditional way to serve spaghetti here  let me show you how a pro does it  well thanks for the meal pal you're  welcome or as they say in Italian prego  why do you always have to make it about  them you know I have feelings too prego  it means you're welcome